[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and if
you remember the first nexus 7 that was
one of the most popular android tablets
of all time mostly thanks to that bang
for the buck ratio it was a lot of
tablet for a very low price so here
comes the second generation the 2013
nexus 7. it's brand new and while there
are a lot of minor improvements and a
lot to the spec upgrades that you get
with a new version of any device there
are three main reasons why this tablet
can actually be considered the best
android tablet that you can buy right
now for any price so without any further
ado let's go ahead and take a closer
look this is a full review of the 2013
nexus 7. so the first of the three
things that make this tablet so great is
the form factor this is of course a
tablet with a seven inch display and
it's sort of a mid-sized device that
puts it right between one-handed and
two-handed use if you want to type out a
long email or something you can use two
hands on that keyboard or if you just
want to scroll on a magazine or use it
casually it's easily a one-handed device
as well a lot of this is because the
nexus 7 is so light coming down to just
290 grams which is now slightly lighter
than the ipad mini and about the same
thinness as the ipad mini as well which
is impressive and overall it's very
comfortable to hold it has that soft
touch back with gentle curves in your
hand and this also happens to be a very
well balanced tablet which is harder to
do than you might think it's not top
heavy or bottom heavy the battery is
just about where you want it to be and
we'll talk about that a little later but
it's in just the right spot where no
matter how i'm holding it's a pleasure
to use now there are some notable
changes to the outside when compared to
the old nexus 7. those are the bezels
the speaker and the camera on the back
the bezels are indeed thinner on the
sides but bigger on the top and the
bottom which actually makes it a bit
narrower and taller and at first glance
you might think oh those unsightly
bezels why do they do that it looks so
ugly but when you start using the tablet
you soon realize that these bezels are
really the only place to put your
fingers when holding it in landscape
mode watching videos gaming etc so it's
actually a good thing that they put
these there for easier use the speakers
are new and they're pretty good they're
stereo speakers and they're located on
the opposite sides of the back of the
device now yes they're still back-facing
speakers and as someone spoiled by the
nexus 10's front-facing speakers it's
kind of hard to go back to these
rear-facing tablet speakers but on the
whole these are quite nice at normal
volumes and they distort a little bit at
high volumes but i think this is one of
the parts of the tablet where they
skimped a little bit to save money and
tried to enhance it after the fact using
some virtual surround sound software it
didn't really work these are just you
know normal sounding stereo speakers and
then we're at that 5 megapixel
rear-facing camera
i just want to say it's a camera on a
tablet i wouldn't expect it to be good
in any way and at this point it kind of
confuses me why they chose to include it
anyway the images and video it takes are
pretty muted in color not very sharp and
this nexus 7 is 30 bucks more expensive
than the first generation couldn't they
have hit that magical 199 price point
again if they didn't include this cheap
crappy camera sensor and glass on the
back
i don't know who knows but you know you
still look at it and feel a little bit
awkward taking pictures on your tablet
anyway so i would just ignore the fact
that there's a camera on this one now
the second thing the second thing that
makes this tablet so magnificent and
it's easily my favorite feature is the
new display it's not just a great
display for a tablet that's only 230
bucks it's a great display for a tablet
period i love the nexus 7's new display
and anyone who loves pixels with me will
love it too it's a 1920 by 1200 panel
which gives it a pixel density of 323
pixels per inch that's the sharpest of
any tablet on the market right now it's
also the best viewing angles and colors
of any tablet on the market right now
it's also an ips display that gets
brighter than any other tablet on the
market right now it's just phenomenal
it's incredibly responsive every time i
turn it on i smile a little bit because
using a tablet with a display like this
is such a pleasure it makes you never
want to put it down so that leaves the
third and final reason that this tablet
has stolen my heart and that is the
operating system it's a nexus now listen
i've used a lot of android tablets and
phones out there and there are a lot of
great android skins on phones that are
actually catching up to the fluidity and
experience from stock android since 5 on
htc one is a good example that's
becoming a more even playing field but
there is nothing just nothing else that
comes close to a nexus experience on
tablets right now i have serious trouble
recommending an android tablet that
isn't running stock android or something
close to it the nexus 7 is no exception
it performs beautifully well inside of
it is a 1.5 gigahertz sort of beefed up
snapdragon s4 pro which is a great chip
and 2 gigabytes of ram but by the way it
performs and handles all the
simultaneous apps and multitasking
general everyday use and responsiveness
i really don't care what's inside
because this thing kicks ass now i did a
separate video all about the newest
features of android 4.3 so if you want
to check that out it'll be in the
description right below that like button
but overall new customizations and trim
support especially are just a home run
on this tablet so much fun to use in
fact i would think i think fun is a
great word to describe this tablet i
found that if someone recommended an app
or something for me to check out i could
just download it install it and start
playing it in a matter of seconds
without a hint of any sort of delay
which is great i've had a lot of fun
using this tablet it really nails the
experience and the performance in the
graphics as you can see here with all
the reflections and live rendering and
physics that's going on it's as high-end
as it gets right now i mean if you want
to play games this tablet is so
lightweight it's almost a no-brainer
thanks to the form factor now all of
this awesome stuff comes with one major
downside remember how i told you the
nexus 7 is the same thinness as the
first gen ipad mini
yeah it's thinner than last year's nexus
7 which means it also has a smaller
battery in physical size we're looking
at a 3950 milliamp hour battery here
this all means it won't last quite as
long during regular constant use you'll
probably get about eight or nine hours
out of it but what's nice is it burns
almost no battery in standby mode i had
one night where i forgot to plug it in
at 27 and i woke up the next morning and
i was at 26 so it's also a really really
power sipper when it's in standby and
it's also compatible with the chi
standard for wireless charging so if you
pick up a couple wireless chargers you
can have them in convenient locations
maybe an office or your home so you
never really have to worry about battery
life but you should know that this is
indeed a smaller physical battery than
the last nexus 7. but dude this tablet
is so much fun you'd be hard-pressed to
find something that's genuinely bad to
say about it i've enjoyed using this
tablet so much during the time that i've
had it i honestly think you will too so
at the end of the day the nexus 7 is
another great tablet and it's got a lot
of reasons to upgrade to it over the old
nexus 7 or any other android tablet out
there just because the price is so good
the performance is so good and the
display especially is so good i i could
recommend this tablet for just about
anyone i'm likely going to be switching
to this as my main tablet from the nexus
10 that i was using earlier just because
it's a lot smaller and more portable but
it keeps that awesome display i love the
nexus 10 display but now i also love the
nexus 7 display and this is more
portable so i'll be able to put all my
textbooks on here and not carry a ton of
heavy things in my backpack all the time
either way that's been it thank you for
watching this brand new review of this
brand new tablet if you enjoyed it
definitely feel free to give a thumbs up
below but more importantly if you want
to see more videos like this in the
future there's a subscribe button below
for you guys to hit if you're signed in
either way thank you for watching and i
will talk to you guys in the next video
[Music]
you